hey why don't we go ahead and get
started welcome everyone to Thursday
demise conference we're trying a little
experiment today of course I worried all
night whether anyone was going to show
up and I'm glad to see those people here
anyways what what our experiment is is
that our group our research group really
works as a group so I thought rather
than one person doing it we would do it
as a panel although I know that our
fourth panelist is not here yet but
hopefully I'll be here anyway so we're
gonna talk today about work that we do
our regular project funded by a couple
grants which I'll acknowledge on the
next slide and our the focus of our work
is reusing EHR data for various clinical
tasks in in this case two tasks in
particular cohort selection and rare
disease surveillance and we'll describe
how we're gonna do that
so our speakers are myself bill Hirsch
I will then hand off to Steve Chamberlin
our postdoc who probably most of you
know he's was an NLM postdoc and now
he's a postdoc in this project Aaron
Cohen a professor in the department and
when he gets here Steve Bedrich who is
associate professor in the department
and also a PhD graduate of our program
so this work is funded by two grants one
of them is federal from the National
Library Medicine and our one that
originated with Steven whoo some of you
may remember dr. woo who was here and
then left to follow his wife to do an
ophthalmology fellowship and l9 Lam
pharmaceuticals so it's also some
industry funding although we're really
not working on their products per se
although we're developing methods that
may enable them to better I
by candidates for their products okay so
so I'm just gonna accidentally go back
so I'm gonna give an overview of our
background and methods weights gonna try
to limit our comments to ten minutes
which means I've already gone 7 or 3 I
have 7 left Steve is going to talk about
the cohort discovery project all of this
at a fairly high level Aaron the rare
disease detection and then Steve bedrick
some of the future directions for our
work so I think you all know that my
research focus since I was an NLM fellow
way back when has been an information
retrieval I've written a book on the
topic it's that particular edition is a
little bit out of date but there's a new
one coming and you've all done search
information retrieval whether you go to
Google or PubMed we do it for different
reasons you might be looking for
information on something we focus on to
use cases in this work one is patient
cohort discovery so basically doing a
search to try to identify patients who
might be candidates for clinical studies
and then the second one is rare disease
surveillance looking for the presence of
rare often under diagnosed diseases in
this case one in particular there is a
little bit of history of this actually
next week some of you will be heading
off to the AMI and meeting me too but
before then Maxo going to another
meeting called Trek the text retrieval
conference that is this annual challenge
evaluation mostly non-medical but
because of my and and others efforts
have always had a medical task in there
so a challenge evaluation for different
research groups to compare their methods
on a standardized data set we actually
had a medical records data set for what
we called the trek medical records track
a number of years ago it's challenging
with medical records because of all the
privacy concerns this there was actually
a de-identified data set from the
University of Pittsburgh
it's no longer in widespread use for a
variety of reasons there's another one
out there that some of you may have
heard of called mimic but it's been a
real challenge for this kind of research
because there isn't there are not
readily shareable large data sets
Stephen Wu then was awarded in our one
from the National Library Medicine
he actually moved here when his and XE
we were already collaborators but he
moved here because his wife came to do a
residency in ophthalmology and so he was
on our faculty for the duration while
she was here and because he came from
the Mayo Clinic we basically do our
methods in parallel although we can't
share data we can only share our methods
and results so there's a variety of ways
that we measure success in information
retrieval you you actually don't think
about it explicitly but maybe implicitly
when you search am i finding everything
I'm looking for
what's my recall and are my results
precise am I getting things about what
I'm looking for and those are the
measures that information retrieval and
many other fields use called recall and
precision you can actually combine these
two measures because sometimes you want
an aggregate single measure the simplest
and most common way is the F measure
that basically lets you set a proportion
on whether you want recall to be more
important or precision to be more
important then there's some more complex
aggregate measures and the one you'll
hear about with us often times you for a
variety reasons you may not have enough
relevance judgments so this B pref
measure is a useful measure when you
have a lot of data that's not been
judged if you don't have the resources
or the the records are big like in the
case of medical records
so most of you in the room who are
clinicians know what medical records
look like this is my weak attempt at art
to try to show what a medical record
looks like and the the the kind of
take-home message from this is that as
single patient's medical record has a
lot of elements a lot of diverse kinds
of data some of its structured data
some of it is unstructured data textual
data and it it's challenging for a
variety of reasons not the least of
which is that it needs to sit on a very
secure server because the data in our
case is from OHSU patients and if you're
like me there is about a one in five
chance that your records in the
collection actually checked mine didn't
make the cut but anyways it may be in
there we have an IRB protocol and and
restrictions on who can access it who
can use it and so forth this is just a
table of the different types there's
about the original data set had a
hundred thousand patients we actually
for the rare disease project got some
additional data but it pretty much has a
complete medical record all the notes
problem lists lab results medications
Hospital encounters things like that and
it's we get it in XML and actually are
due to our former graduate Brian Laraway
who now works for oak tree it was the
analyst who helped us get the data after
we've received the IRB protocol and the
way that we judge the success well the
the way we judge how well our algorithms
work measuring that recall and precision
is actually having people Steve
Chamberlain's done some of that work
we've had other medical students
informatics students others and actually
Steve bedrick who's here now
originally developed this interface to
do different kinds of relevance
judgments and this is the one that we
use for judging whether a patient should
or not be retrieved or either a cohort
selection task or a rare disease like
acute intermittent porphyria which Aaron
will talk about and so this too is an
applique is it's a web application but
it's sitting on a secure server and only
people who are on the research team
approved by the IRB can access it so the
use cases then for a work as I've said
one is cohort discovery which is offered
these days by a lot of medical centers
including OHSU but it's actually not
been that well studied there's not that
many papers that people published about
how well it works so one use case is can
we retrieve cohorts of patients kind of
like doing a search for specific
clinical studies Steve will give some
examples of that and then the rare
disease detection work that Aaron will
talk about so I'm gonna turn it over to
Oh everybody I'm Steve thanks for okay
so the arrows advance yeah okay okay so
the last year so I've been working on
evaluating and comparing different
methods for cohort retrieval using the
EHR data and this is I put the list
again of the different data types to
emphasize that this is patient level
it's not data or document level so that
adds a level of complexity we did this
using the Cranfield information
retrieval evaluation methodology which
built that's describes some of the
components of already so it it involves
it requires a test test set of data
which we've already talked about we have
about a hundred thousand patients this
is live data from EHR and then we have
to have topics that we search for in
that data so we've identified fifty-six
topics or cohorts which are actual
requests that we've had either at OHSU
or the Mayo Clinic and and I am one of
the 100,000 and then we and then we want
to check we want to test different
methods so we're comparing really two
main categories of methods we have we
have word base what we're calling
automated word based queries so these
are strictly word based queries and and
then we have semi structured boolean
queries so the idea of the semi
structured is that that's our kind of
our gold standard that we want to
compare the word based queries to the
word based queries actually have
different parameters that we varied so
there's 48 iterations for each topic on
the word based queries and these the
other big difference between the two is
the word based queries are ranked as as
we talked about so those those come with
relevant scores and they're ranked by
relevance a boolean query is a I didn't
use sequel but it's essentially a sequel
query so so as the name says it's at
either matches or a doesn't so there's
no ranking and
and then talked about the the interface
so this is again this is a clinically
trained person goes in and actually
assesses the different pools that we
pull back from the different methods and
and then just scores just Flags each
patient as either relevant possibly
relevant or not relevant at all
so and we pulled for the automated
queries we pulled random samples from
all four xlviii iterations for each of
the topics and for the semi-structured
billion queries we couldn't do all of
them because of time but we pulled we
selected ten and we did a full
evaluation of everything returned so
then we take that data and we use a
program called trek eval to generate the
statistics and for this analysis we did
I use only would recall precision and
beep referent recall precision don't
require ranking so those were good for
comparing the boolean queries to the
word based queries and the B proof is a
ranked statistic so we is that more for
evaluating that the word based queries
and the variations across the different
parameters so the last thing we did is
we we we got interested in decomposing a
topic so what what characteristics in a
topic might affect the performance and
and also might affect what kind of a
method you choose to query that topic so
we called that our topic taxonomy these
were structural or content oriented and
then we did a predictive model we did a
beta regression predictive model with
simulated data to try to look at the is
there some sort of interaction between
these taxonomy characteristics and the
methods that you select so these are
these are some examples of the topics we
had 56 again these are examples kind of
a summary example in a more detailed
example and I'd mentioned that there are
four parameters for the runt for the
word based queries and these are the
before parameters that were varied and
so all possible combinations equals 48
iterations the first one is kind of
important the topic representation the a
virgin summary statement is kind of like
what's in the right column summary
statement for the topic B is a
an actual case study example for that
topic and then C is a detailed criteria
that's really the structured or semi
structured version so that would have a
lot of codes ICD and CPT codes and maybe
some text text subset is you know do we
search just the notes or all the
document types so we're pulling back a
lot of documents per patient a lot of
you multiple documents from a data type
multiple data types and those all have
relevant scores so we have to come up
with a patient level relevant score and
that's and so we used a couple of
different aggregation methods and then
the retrieval models themselves at the
bottom alright so this slide it's a lot
of box plots and this is this is just
the word base query performance and
these are all this is all based on the B
prep statistics so I have 48 box plots
in each box block as one of the 48
iterations for the word based queries
and the boxplot distribution is our the
56 topics distribution of the
performance of the 56 topics so I won't
go into a lot of detail here I think
some of the main patterns this this
middle section is topic representation B
and all of the sub iterations below that
so that tends to perform and overall a
little bit better than the other so this
is the case case study representation
and then the other thing to note is you
can kind of see their little blocks of
for where the median lines don't really
change so we didn't see a lot of
variation those are the those are the
retrieval models and we really didn't we
saw probably the least amount of
variation across the retrieval models
and then I flipped it around so this is
these are 56 topics are 56 box plots one
for each of the topics and then it's the
distribution of performance across the
48 iterations of the word based queries
so this is ordered by the median value
you can see there's a big range and
performance and then you know overall
the performances is fairly low for the
word based query so most of the medians
are below 0.25 B pref
and then the other thing it's
interesting is that there are some that
have huge variation across the
parameters and some that don't so that
kind of sparked some interest and can we
tease
you know some structural components
those queries that that point to certain
parameters that work better than others
and so now this slide is getting into
the comparison with the boolean queries
which are which are the gold standard
and again those are all handwritten very
time-consuming and the word based
queries are all automated and purely
word based queries so the balloon this
is precision which is you know the
percent of what's returned that are
judged to be relevant and the blue line
is the relevance of the word based
queries and the red line is the
relevance of the boolean queries so you
can see there's a performance better
performance from the boolean queries
this is we in this case since we didn't
judge all of the everything returned
from all 56 topics for the boolean
queries we just looked at the overlap
between the boolean query and the judge
word pools that makes sense so so that's
how we got this statistic we just looked
at the precision in that pool and that
there's only a single data point for the
word based queries because this is the
precision of the actual judged pool
which is a random sample across all 48
iteration so we did go in we decided to
go in and pick ten topics and do full
judgment of everything returned by the
boolean queries and then compare that to
the distribution across the word based
branch our query parameters and so that
the red triangles took like hearts or
that's the performance of the boolean
query and then then I went back to the
distribution of precision for their word
based queries and again you know there's
their performance which is what we
expected in this case so the last slide
so this is the query taxonomy and we did
several things here but these are six
characteristics these are binary Flags
and these are all attempts attempts at
capturing different aspects of structure
and a topic and temporal is that there's
some sort of time based sequencing in
the topic like order of events is
important text is actually that the
topic can't be represented strictly by
structured data that
also requires some text and that really
applies to semi-structured medication is
that a medication you know was required
for the topic a procedure is some sort
of procedures required either surgery or
a lab test and additional is that
additional values were required so the
lab test values would be have to be
checked for this topic and then
condition is that that that an actual
medical condition was required in the
topic and not all of them required
medical conditions some were just
screening exams so this is what this is
is change in be prep or the the impact
on performance that these different
flags have or components have and we did
this we trained the model with our
actual data a beta regression model but
we we predicted on simulated data which
at every possible combination of the
four parameters or what basically
parameters in these six flags so the
main takeaway is that increased
complexity generally decreases
performance except for text which is
interesting kind of unexpected that the
presence the requirement for text and
talk in addition to structured data sort
of improve those those topics tended to
do better and this is all word based
query and then I won't go into this but
this is this is the last figure and I'm
we were trying to get it at an
interaction which is really the the goal
of the model and interaction between
those six flags which are on the column
on the right and then the 48 parameter
iterations which are law along the
bottom and you can see the flags are one
zeroes that's all possible combinations
of the flags the only point here is that
there are there are obviously patterns
as has been clustered it's sort of match
certain parameters do better were
certain combinations of these flags and
that could you know that could lead to
something in the query guiding what
method is selected
it's the clicker
so I'm gonna back up a little bit talk
about like why we do all this for a
minute so there are over 1200 rare
disorders in known in the world well a
rare disorder is something that affects
less than one and 200,000 patients
worldwide as you can imagine because
they're rare people don't think about
them and they are highly under diagnosed
one particular rare disease that we
looked at for this work is acute
intermittent porphyria which is a
genetic disease which causes mistakes in
heme biosynthesis and that's this
affects like 5 and a million patients
worldwide right so we're talking really
really low prevalence but patients that
have the disease there's a significant
you know morbidity there's a significant
effect on their quality of life
they have intermittent but sort of
constantly intermittent if you will
keeps coming back and back them back
neuro visceral symptoms including
abdominal pain nausea and vomiting
weakness psychiatric changes to make
this even more tricky
there's variable penetrants people can
have the genetic defect did not really
have the symptoms so to be diagnosed
they actually have to have the the
symptoms they have to have genetic
defect and they have to have a positive
test and there is a definitive positive
test for AIP
which is an expensive urine test for a
purple balloon in June I can never say
this word Bill's laughing at me I just
can't say it but it's that thing that's
spelled out right there on the slide now
maybe this didn't used to be as big a
deal because the treatments were not
very specific in the past and I guess
they did help some but now you know with
more advanced research there's like RNA
silencing treatments and things like
that that are that are that are really
very effective they're also very
expensive but they're really very
effective so now you know delaying the
diagnosis of these patients for years
because they have these sort of general
symptoms that overlap with other things
and they come in and they think it's one
thing you know maybe they think it's
irritable bowel and it goes away and
then they come back and they don't get
diagnosed for years and they're
suffering with this and they don't
really know what it is you know
now there's treatments and it's
important to identify these patients
sooner and get them treated so that they
have a better quality of life so you
know the question is you know this is
the 21st century we have EHRs we have
all this data you know can we practice
some kind of 21st century medicine and
use all these tools that we have to
identify patients that are needing to be
screened for these rare diseases in this
case what we studied was this particular
example of acute intermittent porphyria
so can this be done right we can't
screen everybody the screening test is
cheap but we can't screen a million
people right but we can screen a hundred
people we can screen maybe a thousand
people we'll see so how do we do this
what we actually expanded the data set
that bill mentioned the original data
set that was used for the information
retrieval that had a hundred thousand
patients we updated it too it's actually
two hundred and twenty thousand patients
and and we got a new a new pull of this
so it had you know updated icd-10 codes
and a number of things that were not
available when the original poll was
done and in addition we enriched this
with all the patients that we could find
that had any mention of pork in their
diagnosis or the lab tests or their
notes are anywhere we don't think these
patients have Bart for area by the way
at least not most of them we just wanted
to cast as wide and that as possible
with our original data bill showed you
the diagram of the basically the
different document types includes notes
includes medications includes lab tests
and things like that
and each of these we wound up treating
is a different is a different document
type and we divided the patients in two
cases the positive cases in the negative
cases the
positive cases were the patients that
had EA t 21 which is the specific icd-10
code for AIP and not every patient that
has that in the record actually has a ap
we also do manual review and we wound up
with 30 positive R and manually
confirmed cases of AIP and all the rest
of the data
220,000 patients minus 30 is the
negative training set where the we're
assuming that for the purposes of
building a model that they don't have a
IP we'll get that to that minute so what
was the approach very very high level
because I don't have a lot of time to
get into this but we parsed each one of
those documents each record into
different features and we labeled each
feature by what document it came from
because if a if an icd-10 code came from
a problem list that's different than if
it comes from a visit code so we labeled
all the features with where they came
from
we scored it by the frequency of
appearance because we were looking at
their medical records log Natuna ly so
we wanted to know for example that
somebody have a chief complaint of
abdominal pain once or 20 times that
turns out to be relevant here and what
we did first remember we've only got 30
positive cases we've got 220,000
negative cases and we have lots and lots
of features that you know are very
specific to porphyria the note could say
patient has acute intermittent porphyria
they could have the diagnosis code they
could have there's a specific treatment
called Heymann for acute intermittent
porphyria which could be part of their
record all of these are giveaways and
and and if you're trying to score a lot
in a machine learning contest that would
be great because they're good clues and
you can find these patients but that's
not what we're trying to do here what
we're trying to do here is we're fine
trying to find patients that should be
suspect of having acute intermittent
porphyria and art so we're trying to
look for four features
these generic symptoms and generic
patterns of care that are associated
with maybe needing them for furia tests
that they didn't have and we're not for
the most part that interested in
patients that the medical system already
has suspicions that they have purpura
and has already given a test to and has
already followed up so what we did was
we take off took all these features we
scored them and then we did a univariate
analysis on all these features I can't
remember how many a million features
something like that including all the by
grams and yoonah grams that we parsed
out of all the notes and we did a number
of filtering processes on those features
looking for things that occurred in a
sufficient number of records that had a
sufficient a statistical p-value that
has a sufficiently high odds ratio in
terms of predicting the 30 positive
cases that we knew about and we wound up
with you know and then we sort of took I
think the top hundred from each document
type and then when we went through those
manually and manually removed features
that where it was obvious that there was
clinical knowledge that the patient had
poor Furio or was already suspect for
porphyria so you know we took away all
the obvious stuff we took away that they
are treated with him and we took away
all the ICD codes that were directly
associated with him and we wound up
doing this kind of an iterative fashion
because the more we looked at it and the
more we sort of track down what some of
the codes meant because some of these
codes were very specific
Oh Hsu lab codes and things because
that's how they show up in our data we
had to drill down and see what they
meant and see if well is that really
associated with with suspicion of having
poor fury or is that more of a general
thing so you know the lab tests for
Europe or that Orpha blood that word we
took out but the fact that they had many
urinary samples we left in because
that's sort of an indication of how many
times
they were intersected with the with the
healthcare system and how many times you
know it was thought to check their urine
even though they didn't check it for
portable antigen and then we did a
number of different kind of model
creation we chose to use the SVM with
the RBF kernel basically just based on
using cross-validation with the data
that we had and we built a final model
using all the data and then took that
model and applied it back to all the
debt to all the negative patients
scoring all those negative patients now
normally you'd kind of think that that'd
be highly biased but the thing is we
only wound up with about a hundred
features they're only 30 positive cases
so most of the negatives didn't really
participate very much in creating the
the in creating the the support vectors
in the support vector machine so anyway
we wound up with a score across all the
patients who were thought to be negative
and we can rank those patients by that
score then what we did is we did some
filtering and we we actually created two
filtered sets to manually review but I
think I'm only going to talk about one
set here so what we did was we filtered
out anybody that had a porphyria
diagnosis anybody that had a urinary
test for for porphyria and anybody that
had mentioned of porphyria and note so
we really wanted these patients to be
ranked that had no suspicion essentially
documented in the chart over here and
then we applied our ranking to them took
the top hundred just it's a hundred
because we could that's what Steve could
manually review Manly Steve manually
reviewed the charts and came up with you
know essentially he ate one very likely
case three likely cases in 18 possible
cases you know so that's 22 cases where
one would think it's worth suggesting
that the page
have this simple urine test right what
you would think the natural prevalence
based on what I told you five out of MIT
of a million in a hundred you'd expect
you know five what is that half of a
thousandth of a case so if this is
anywhere near suggestive it's a very
powerful way of narrowing down what
patients we should really focus on for
something like this we would be you know
really excited to find one or two
positive tasks out of these patients
okay so what are the next steps we're
gonna follow up with this by doing a
little mini clinical study that I think
we're about to get the IRB approval for
it's just in the last little little
edits but basically the way we're going
to do this is we're going to contact the
primary providers of those patients
where we think it's useful to have the
urine test and we're gonna tell them
that we had this computer model and went
through all the patients and their
history we identified their patient as
not having one of these tests and having
symptom ology that is compatible with
porphyria and they should consider
giving the patient this test and if they
want they you have a local disease
expert Tom Dulari who is an expert in
porphyria
and you know he's available for
consultation either with the clinician
or with the patient if the clinician
thinks that that's relevant and then
we're gonna just track this we're gonna
see how many tests get done how many are
positive with the natural history of
these patients and hopefully we'll be
able to find some patients who are
undiagnosed and do some actual medical
good with outlets so that's it right
next slide next slide is Steve
right
yeah
okay so future directions with all of
this stuff we started doing this work
under an ro1 that we had with Mayo
Clinic it's expired and we submitted our
is sort of basically expired and we're
spending we've submitted of renewal to
continue this work and all of the things
that bill and Steve and Aaron have
talked about continue Florida are part
of it but we also have some new IR and
machine learning that we're gonna have
to be part of it as well and sort of the
argument that we made to the NLM was
that one of the things that we learned
from doing this and from other projects
is the patient retrieval for cohorts of
EHR data is respond mentally different
than traditional document retrieval
which you know as in looking at it from
a IR standpoint it's just a kind of a
kind of a different animal the
traditional way of doing IR and sort of
a to a rough approximation natural
language processing for a sort of
document classification and scoring is
you find some way does this thing have a
laser pointer that you find some way to
take a document and make a
representation out of it and that could
be a list of the words that occur in it
it could be some kind of vector space
representation lots of ways to do it you
do the same thing with the query
hopefully in a way that's comparable you
come up with some way to compute that
score and there's about a million
different ways that one could compute
that score and then you score all of
your documents against a query and you
pick the ones that have the highest
score right and it's sort of like the
general high-level framework and in
practice personally in IR we would have
used bag-of-words approach right just a
list of words and I kind of touched on
this in escape that's a traditional way
for patients though that's tricky so the
document we're talking about is an
entire patient right and there's a lot
in a patient Bella had that figure that
we're gonna revisit in a minute
different patients are very
heterogeneous from each other just in
terms of what the data looks like some
have a lot of data some have very little
data some of them have
kind of medications some have no
medications and those differences are
often what we want to capture but the
process of smashing a whole patients
into a single representation is a very
lossy way to do that we lose a lot of
information within a patient there's
often a lot of heterogeneity in ways
that are important so Steve touched on
the different dimensions of the queries
and highlighted that some queries care a
lot about medications some queries care
a lot about temporal things that happen
did X happen before Y right again taking
a whole patient smashing into a single
representation often especially doing it
in a general-purpose way that will work
for a lot of different kinds of queries
he erases that information the queries
themselves are very different than sort
of traditional search queries right you
know what car should I buy is like a
nice short little fragment you know or
what what diseases are caused by drug X
or cured by drug X kind of a you know a
nice reason we start your thing the
topics that Steve talked about are these
very long involved you know patients who
had one of these things but not one of
those things who had them before this
thing happened and then had a bad effect
of this other thing right so very long
involved queries and then again the
temporal dependencies all of these
things make the kind of traditional
approach to query and document
representation and not work
heterogeneity just to make that a little
more concrete we saw this figure of a
sort of prototypical patient with like a
really rich deep record of all these
encounters of different kinds some
patients look like that patients who had
a lot of things go on or who we have a
lot of data for over a long period of
time or both how their patients look
more like this and if we think in terms
of sparsity right for machine learning
standpoint this is a much sparser record
and as much sparser note so the same
approaches might might not work a
approach to applying modern machine
learning to patient retrieval has been
to make what are called patient
embeddings this is like a slightly
fancier way of Smashing a whole patient
into a single embedding there's a whole
variety of approaches typically the way
they work is you kind of sort of split
up a patient and do a few different
dimensions you care about demographics
medications diagnosis some
representation of the note text you
learn a separate representation for each
dimension of the patient then you smush
those together and do a vector and then
you do machine learning from there and
that has actually and you can do that
representation in different ways here
I'm showing
using recurrent neural network
architecture but you can do it in any
way you care to think about it's a very
flexible framework it addresses some of
the problems that I've mentioned in
terms of you know it's better than just
taking like all of the text in the whole
patient record and treating it as a bag
of words for traditional retrieval but
it's it doesn't take into account any of
that nuance and doesn't really handle
the heterogeneity if you have a patient
here with a thousand medications versus
one medication that medication
representation you'd need to find a good
way to do it so what we're proposing to
do is to explicitly capture temporal
features of encounters and patients
we're going to learn encounter specific
embeddings that you know might look like
what I just showed you but they be for
one encounter right they'd be focused on
capturing what is happening with this
patient at this point in time and then
we're going to explore ways to compose
those together into richer patient level
embeddings in a way that lets us
explicitly encode time into it so
hopefully it will learn to represent you
know that a patient who had a happened
before B would look different than a
patient that had B happen before a it's
sort of the idea we don't exactly know
how we're going to do it but in the
grant we laid out some ideas that
hopefully are reasonably sound I guess
we'll find out if we get the grant or
not and and go from there and then once
we have these we are going to use them
in retrieval and we're gonna use them in
a slightly different way than then
things typically get use so using these
sort of dense neural embeddings for a
tree vole often follows the same kind of
simplistic scoring approach that people
use like a traditional cosine similarity
or some other kind of similarity metric
between your query and your document and
what we're proposing to do is because so
many of the queries have explicit
temporal dependencies in them we're
going to use an attention mechanism
which if you're not familiar with that I
can't describe it in five seconds but
I'll try the idea is when you have input
that has multiple time steps to it it's
a way of learning having a neural
network learn which time steps are
important for satisfying a particular
query
it's a frequently used in machine
translation to help with word reordering
and we're going to try applying the same
thing to retrieval so that's our sort of
computational next step with all of this
and we'll see you know many of many of
the things that you know Steve
identified in his analysis of the topics
and that Aaron identified as relevant
features on the career work we think we
can use that information to help us
train these monstrosities of networks
using you know by by coming up with new
kind of training strategies that take
that into account so I think that's all
we had that's the gist of what we've
done we tried to finish early enough to
open the floor to any questions or
comments XE and let me make the comment
to that well there's there's actually we
actually have a score on the grant and
it's potentially in the fundable range
but but this project actually is going
on and there's opportunity for students
and and others to get involved as well
so feel free to talk to us if you're
interested but let me open the floor to
questions comments it's a great project
so I had a question about the like
validation so I think there were like 20
possible probable and and very likely
and I was curious to know are you
planning to valley just like with the
traditional clinical test for a IP or
perhaps casting a wider net
it's not doesn't fit the exact classical
presentation of AIP because from my
vague recollection of porphyria it's
kind of group of illnesses and I would
still think that the approach would be
useful even if if the like outcome isn't
that like you know same no none of those
patients are actually diagnosed with
their fury and like perhaps they have a
very like similar genetic mutation that
just manifests slightly differently and
what your plans are for doing that yeah
that's a good question I mean the model
is really specific to a IP meaning that
that's what we trained it on we don't
have any real good reason to think how
it's gonna act on different for fury of
variants the you know certainly given I
think the clinical review that Steve did
they need the urine cast as a as a you
know as a diagnostic right to to know if
they have that particular disease I mean
we depending on you know how much the
how excited the clinicians are about
this and how much they want to
collaborate with us and with dr. Dulari
you know I would be delighted if that
motivated them to you know drill a
little deeper into you know
copal porphyria and some other very poor
Furio variants you know other mistakes
in heme metabolism and all that I mean I
can't say that we have any particularly
data from this algorithm that it
particularly helps with that or not but
yeah you have some patients with weird
recurring or visceral symptoms that as
far as we can tell don't have a
definitive diagnosis in the chart
you know if this motivates them to look
a little more broadly I would definitely
consider that to be you know a win even
you know confirm any aap cases you know
it's not so you know unlike a lot of
machine learning that's totally
unexplainable there's a little bit of
explain ability but we're not we're
actually not we're really you know
turning the record into a big vector and
finding other patients that have no
mention of porphyria but are otherwise
close to it I mean there could be in
fact maybe some of the methods that
Steve talked about kind of drilling down
you know may be helpful and you know as
over time as we get more resources judge
more patients we can actually test out
these models further and see see how
they work so um this was all really
interesting thank you what is the
distinction between this tool and the
existing I to be to court discovery tool
I assume that it's that this is this
tools on the like the live the front end
versus ITB to code court discoveries on
the data warehouse side and also is like
anonymized yeah I you know I to be to is
really an interface to an underlying
database which could be our database I
don't know how our I to be two instance
works but I to be to also only gives you
counts of things right so our programs
that we've written you know go into that
data and process it a lot deeper at
least that's my understanding
I don't know as yeah we have an i to be
to expert here I was just going to say
you can grab
which is that I to be to to least the
way we have it set up here is structured
data only so it's not doing anything
with the notes or mentioned or anything
like that and it's pretty much a you
know a big boolean query tool on the
structured data in the database so it
probably does correspond to one of the
approaches and Steve's graph of all
those different approaches but you know
the approaches that the group is using
or you know much more numerous and and
and some of them a lot more
sophisticated and they're also looking
at the tax so you know the i2b2 tool is
sort of like you know baseline patient
cohort identification tool with
structured data and this work is more
about you know how can we push that
field forward
yeah so I was wondering with the
features that you did identify for the
porphyria part of the project how much
did they differ from features that would
have been selected by talking with
clinical experts or how much overlap was
there so was the machine learning
process really finding something new and
novel to go into this but that iterative
process that we talked about did involve
talking to you know people with clinical
experience so and we and we had to do
that sort of feature editing removal
process to get rid of the stuff that the
question missions already knew so what
would happen is that we would run the
model and and all this stuff would pop
up as highly weighted features highly
that that that clinicians already knew
about and that you know wouldn't help us
to discover any new patients because
they were very focused on the ways that
physicians would treat or document
patients that already had poor Fuhr and
there was actually one case which is
really really interesting
I'll talk to two things one thing was
that the number one of positive
predictive feature was recurrent bouts
of unexplained abdominal pain the the
basically the icd-10 code for that for a
number of episodes or visits with with
that and the other thing that was really
interesting is that we we thought we
made an interesting discovery because we
found that the another strong weighted
feature was Sai mat adine that it seemed
like there was a disproportionate amount
of being treated with Sai meditating for
porphyria patients and we're like oh we
go talk to Tom Volare who is our human
ecology expert and he's like oh yeah we
use that to treat the to treat I didn't
know this but we used that to treat
porphyria because it blocks one of its
side effects is blocking one of the
pathways and that improves their
symptoms so we pulled that out of the
model even though that was you know a
pretty positive
a predictive feature and it was a
discovery for us you know because we
didn't know that so it was it made us
feel good that we were like on the right
track that we were discovering things
that we didn't know even if the
clinicians did know about them the other
thing I would say and this is definitely
true in any kind of sort of clinically
related informatics work is I don't
think we would have accomplished the
same thing if we just talked to the
clinicians and asked them what to use as
features it's much different thing
saying well what feature should we use
and they say you know heme and d20 and
these different things that you know
they used to treat for your patients
it's another thing to come to them with
the list we did this statistical
analysis we've scored these features
with these models and this is what we're
finding and actually they didn't think
to tell us about cimetidine we had to
bring it to them and that for them to
say oh yeah that's right so it really is
sort of this iterative you know machine
and knowledge engineering process that
could get to the point but the features
that are left in the model some of them
are pretty straightforward there's a
number of things that are different ways
to treat pain there are some things that
have to do with psychiatric symptoms
there's abdominal pain and then there's
weird stuff in the model that I don't
know why it's scoring it exactly well
general lab tests like I think I think
getting getting a CBC more frequent than
the background is which may be just a
you know an indirect indicator that they
show up to the emergency room
I essentially have the same question did
you discover any new risk factors that
we wouldn't normally find so you
answered that I just want to say as a
commission this is one of the more
exciting new uses of one of the I was
thinking as Aaron was talking one other
thing we we also pulled some OHSU
specific thing you know like for example
the name to Lowry because Tom is the
doctor of many of these patients that's
a highly predictive but it's it's
completely but it obviously if if we
were gonna apply this outside of Hsu I
think we do want to ask something
anniver oh okay okay
like I would imagine like families that
people who don't know each other
perhaps in a particular medical area say
you did like you know Greater Portland
area etc like is that something that
would come up in your design of this
model
where you know like if you find one
patient at the family they probably all
have it and so we'd have to take that
into account or I mean and you could you
could either do it forward in the
process or backward right backward
it was more thinking the reverse like
you you know you have a patient who like
you actually knew that they had a
relative that's in the same like
training set or in the data set who had
the disease but they don't know that
they're related to that person but
perhaps they like are their names
happens to be the same last name or
there are some other like four or once
we've sequenced everyone of course it
has variable penetrants so the family
members
yeah shower has a place for everything
but you know you might discover this you
might discover
sort of a more detailed
really interesting and so my question
was just kind of scaling up to all the
other rare diseases you kind of envision
this sort of approach reading future
engineering physicians removing features
that are actually in the
the first few times to really understand
the problems bass generate as it is and
is a good way to prevent making bad
mistakes when you're doing something
blind but I also think that in the long
run maybe not for the first set of rare
diseases but eventually that you know
some of these deep learning approaches
especially if we intersect them with you
know learning from medical sources on
you know treatments and things like that
to remove those things as two obvious
indicators you could you could you could
conceive of how you might be able to
automate this on a large scale in in the
long right if you really wanted to right
now I think we're really focusing on
okay well what are the rare diseases
that that have a high value proposition
at least as far as the patients go you
know that where you you want to discover
them they're under diagnosed there's a
good way to treat them so that there's
some value to the patient in that and
they can't be so rare that it's unlikely
so something like that yeah I think in
the long run it may be going beyond rare
diseases going you know more proactively
in general in whatever 21st century
digital digital medicine has there's
lots of things you could do that you
know aren't directly this work but
related this you know when you look at
people's weight curves or whatever you
know over time in your and you're just
more predictive about intervening with
with with them based on you know looking
at the EHR from sort of long the to know
kind of point of view so I mean I think
that kind of stuff can be learned as we
get more experienced
a really good robust
yeah sure so so I had a comment in a
question in the comment is that it's
really exciting to hear this and thank
you for for sharing this research
because clinically the mentality is is
when you hear hoofbeats look for horses
and so you know from a clinical
perspective if somebody comes in with
intermittent abdominal pain porphyria is
one of the last things on my mind and
having this kind of augmented brain to
borrow a Larry weed expression which is
actually you know using machine learning
to look for zebras and present those
zebras to me to kind of counteract the
the way that I think is really exciting
and I think that's going forward in
medicine that is something that is going
to be really useful to clinicians the
question that I had is I'm really
interested in seeing what the clinical
results of the 38 people that you
actually pulled you know when they do
their tests how many of them actually
have porphyria and exactly and and the
reason is because I think this creates a
really interesting paradigm to medicine
which is that as a patient you know they
come to me I don't you know I don't
diagnose it I don't even think of
porphyria and then they get you know a
letter from OHSU saying by the way the
research has shown that you may have
this really rare disease that you need
to get screened for and so as a patient
I get and I get into a panic and then I
and then I watch the madness of King
George and I get into a bigger panic and
and then I actually show up to have this
test and if it's positive that's
fantastic but if it's negative I wonder
what the reaction of patients on what
you guys think the reactions of patients
will get were yeah we're we're trying
but as this technology matures my worry
is that patients are going to there's
going to be a cohort of false positives
that will come out of this invariably
and is that another legal risk thing
that medicine has to take into account
because of this kind of well this is
only suggesting you know and and we're
very you know explicit with the IRB that
we were going to notify their physicians
we don't want to go straight to patients
so it'll so basically the physicians
will will get an email and offering
more information if they want they'll be
able to contact Tom de Lowrey but I so
the 21st century analog is when you all
at 20 centuries when you hear the sound
of hoofbeats think horses in 21st
century it's when you hear the sound of
hoofbeats run a machine learning
outright anyway so that's been waiting
so he'll be the last question can you
hand him the mic I thank you very much
it's a really interesting fuel research
I have sort of two-part questions all
right but the first part is okay if you
focusing a lot on the symptoms or the
patient's - gonna come in a lot of that
information is hidden in three texts
essentially and this what a whole debate
about how to parse that out accurately
and so how you fortunately how you deal
with that second of all if you were
focusing more on a diagnosis part of the
of the part of the medical record do you
have to concern have you ever run into
issues or being able to find out if
there's cluster of diagnoses that point
more toward a epi compared to you know
if you have that cluster of diagnoses
because a lot of this thing in medicine
we do we do differential diagnosis
things that are related to each other
and could be possible and explanation
for the condition have you seen those
cluster coming in like people who are
not being back nose for this ye a IP
happiest cluster of diagnosis
essentially well when you were looking
through the data yeah I mean remember
you know we're we're actually not really
parsing in you know we're not really
parsing out down to understanding what
this disease is we're basically
representing the whole record as a
vector and we're trying to find other
vectors that are similar to it maybe we
might learn that there are actually you
know better approaches to do that maybe
if we selectively apply NLP or something
like that to specific pieces or maybe
these word embeddings might help with
that but for right now our approach is
really just just to look for kind of
global similarity
raus all these features
for certain applications you actually do
need to go all the way down
so you want to give anything more they
have dude the simplest thing possible
first I mean we did parse the notes down
into grams and by grams and some of
those did represent symptoms and they
did pop up you know again probably the
strongest thing is recurrent episodes of
unexplained abdominal pain and then you
know other kinds of psychiatric
manifestations would add to that and it
seemed like that there were some
patterns in the pain being treated with
some drugs as opposed to other drugs
being being relevant to identifying
patients in their visits but you know
that was that was sort of observed
afterwards we didn't we didn't feed that
into the model we saw kind of what the
model tended to focus on so there's a
lot of there's lots of ways of doing it
there's lots you know creating these is
you know general patient representation
vectors you know may may actually help
you know represent things at a more at a
higher and less less particular level
like when bill talks about representing
these patients as vectors these are big
vectors these are like doctors with like
a million dimensions in them and most
patients are mostly zeros in those
vectors so you know having less of a
sparse representation more of a dense
repetative representation might be
advantageous the problem is those dense
representations are a little less easily
explainable what they mean and why two
patients are like each other or what not
so you know this is why it's research
and we'll investigate these things
what we learn right okay well thank you
everyone for your comments